hello everyone and welcome to the sixth
and penultimate round of the meltwater
Champions Chester finals it is
pragnananda vs Magnus cross and this is
the first game of their match and
whenever uh Prague and the Magnus face
off against each other the games are
extremely uh complicated and this one is
no exception uh Prague of course is the
underdog here but he has beaten Magnus
before and uh he will of course try to
do so again so again like I said it's
it's very nice and very complicated game
let's check it out uh Prague with the
white pieces opens with E4 and Magnus
plays C6 he goes for the Karo Khan
defense with D4 D5 and progos for the
advanced variation of the Karo Khan
Ponte E5 with Bishop to F5 and now Pawn
to H4 this is the tall variation against
the uh the Karo Khan H5 and the now
Bishop to D3 offering a trade of light
Square Bishops and here Magnus trade so
captures captures and pawn to E6 this
can be considered even a a classical way
to play play it Knight to F3 we have
Queen to A5 with check and now Knight B
to D2 and here Knight the H6 alireza is
also a big fan of this line with the
black pieces there are a couple of games
he played against very strong opponents
we have castles and now Knights the F5
the Knight is excellently placed here
and as you have upon an H5 it can never
be kicked away with a move like G4 so
Knights the B3 attacks the queen and the
Magnus just offers the queen trade frog
wants the Queens on the board so he
brings the queen back Queen to D1 and
now C5 advancing um the pawn attacking
white strong Center so D captures on C5
and now the short characters and C5
offering the bishop for this knight uh
we have pawned the A4 attacking the
queen queen to C6 and now Knight
characters on C5 Queen captures and C3
now uh Knight to C6 and now there is a
game where Bishop to G5 was played but
here we have Rook to E1 and it is now as
of move 16 that we have a completely new
game and this is basically where our
game begins with Rook to d8
and now uh Bishop to G5 and it's
important to bring this Rook to d8 right
away that as a product did not go Bishop
to G5 in the game that we mentioned that
was played before Bishop to G5 was
played uh right away without that Rook
D1 move and then of course Rook to D it
is impossible but now as Prague
hesitated it will Bishop to G5 Magnus
takes the D file for his Rook so Bishop
G5 now attacks the rook and now just
rooked D7 Magnus decides to keep the
Rook on the D file Rook to C1 and now
Pawn to D4 and this is a very very
interesting Pawn sacrifice as it's not
really a pawn sacrifice if Prague
captures it then the queen just moves
back Queen to B6 and you still have all
this sorry about that all this pressure
against the D4 pawn and also you're
attacking the at B Dupont so we're gonna
grab a pawn back so instead Prague will
spawn to B4 as one always should uh
Queen to B6 and now Pawn to B5 attacking
the Knight but now D captures on C3
opens up and attack towards prox queen
and I know you guys are probably already
wondering what's Queen captures on D7
played and when you see the position
when you when you see the Queen the pawn
captures next the bishop control in this
diagonal The Rook coming to D1 it just
looks like something you should be able
to do and uh White is in fact very close
to achieving this it was not played in
the game but I will show it if Queen
captures and these seven King captures
and phone captures here with check uh
that's not really all that great however
you could play Rook e to D1 check and
now how do you defend this uh you could
move the king uh for example King the C7
or King to E8 but you could also uh well
that's pretty much all you can do if you
go King to E8 then that's pretty bad
then B captures and C 6 B captures and
root captures and C 3 and you are in a
terrible what terrible position here the
queen has to keep an eye on that d8
square otherwise you're getting
checkmated so white would definitely be
better here but you're not forced to go
to E8 you can go to C7 or to C8 and
there your king will be fine if row
captures on C3 now the Knight cannot
move King to B8 and after B captures B
captures uh you get this position where
white only has a rook and the bishop for
a queen but uh the two Rooks Knight and
Bishop could be could be very hard to
deal with with the King being so wide in
the open I don't know it would be
extremely difficult to play the engine
gives black a slight Edge but only only
a slight one uh so it would be fun to
play this but Prague decides to go for
Queen to B3 which is in fact the
strongest move recommended by the engine
uh Knight C to E7 now getting the Knight
out of Harm's Way and The Rook captures
on C3 we have castles Magnus finally
brings his King to safety and queen back
to C2 now with full control over the
over the C file Knight to D5 attacking
the rook and The Rook the C4 we have
rooked the C7 now Magnus offers a trade
and uh what you want to do here is
probably uh just triple up on the C file
or you could maybe even capture on C7
but it's not all that spectacular for
example if Ro captures Queen captures
Queen captures Knight captures uh what
what do you play fructose C1 you kind of
grab the C file but after the Knight
moves you don't really have any access
to the uh to the to the C file it's
completely closed off by Black's pieces
so instead of practice Knight to D2 and
not Magnus uh just doubles Rooks on the
C file Rook captures on C7 Rook captures
and now Queen to D1 putting pressure on
the H5 pawn and Magnus says you can have
that pawn I'm going for Queen to D4
nicely centralizing the queen and
attacking the A4 Pawn because if uh
Magnus survives any incoming attack that
might be coming on the king side he will
have a 2 one advantage probably a two to
zero advantage on the on the queen side
and he should be able to push those
pawns so here uh Prague goes for Queen
captures on H5 uh Queen captures an A4
and now Knight to E4 now praga says I'm
not into pawns anymore I'm going for
checkmate here and we'll see if Magnus
can defend this he grabs the pawn queen
captures on B5 now if Prague cannot end
the game then the two connected pass
pawns will be too much to handle uh Rook
to D1 and now we have Rook the D7 by
Magnus interestingly Rook to C4 is very
very unpleasant for white it attacks the
Knight and really asks what you do here
yeah but Magnus decides to go for Rook
to D7 Queen to G4 by proc getting the
queen out of Harm's Way also there are
some tricks with Knight to F6 check and
uh to give you an idea of what could
happen let's say Knights the B6 if you
play something like this you wanna trade
Rooks because why wouldn't you uh Knight
to F6 check and if G captures then you
can play best of the D2 and now it's a
it's a force to draw that's kind of the
point and if King to f8 Bishop uh if you
go go to the H file then just Queen to
H5 check Queen G4 check Queen H5 check
will be a Perpetual but if you go to f8
then we can play Bishop to B4 with check
Knight the E7 and now even e captures on
F6 now the Knight cannot move the Knight
will hang characters on the one Queen
capture Sandy one and now Knights to D5
Bishop captures on E7 and you can't
really capture if you capture then Queen
here with check ends the game uh you
have to block with the queen and then
Pawn captures an E7 uh Will Will just uh
Force black to resign you you're gonna
lose a full Queen so you're not gonna be
able to do that right away yeah instead
after Bishop capture 77 you're gonna
have to play King to E8 and then okay
the game continues Bishop to A3 and so
on white would be better but uh probably
maybe not not quite enough or maybe
maybe he would it's hard to say uh but
uh you know uh that's what happens if if
you go some like Knight to B6 which is
interesting it does happen but not right
away first Magnus plays King to f8 and
now we have Queen to H5 by Prague now
also having pressure on the H file King
back to G8 and Prague repeats Queen to
G4 and only now Magnus goes Knight to B6
and now we can go into the line that
we've discussed if you want you can play
Knights to F6 check and it's a force to
draw but in the game Bishop to F6 was
played by Prague he is now threatening
some very nasty stuff here also the
Knight cannot move because you would
just get checkmated but this doesn't
work for one very specific reason the
program missed uh well something that's
not easy to find so feel free to pause
the video and win this game for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds
what's the what's the move that the prog
missed
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
second move of the combination as the
first one uh well the first one is also
super important because you kind of have
to free the square for the second move
and that is Rook capture Sun D1 with
check Queen captures on D1 and now
Knight to D7 or Knight to D5 it's
important to go after that Bishop on F6
uh and to close off the D file that's
the idea uh and now or if you go for
this then again it's a force to draw you
can just play Knight captures and F6
checking G7 and queen to d8 and you have
sufficient resources for a draw if
Knight to H6 you don't care just Knight
H5 check King H7 Knight to F6 check King
G7 I2 H5 check if you go here then Queen
to G5 will of course uh be uh winning so
you're gonna have to settle for a
Perpetual here but after Rook captures
on D1 and queen captures on D1 Magnus
finds Knight to D7 and this is now
completely winning for him uh and if you
go for queen G4 you don't really have
anything here of course the black will
not go after after the bishop black will
just capture the pawn on E5 and now
after Bishop captures Queen captures uh
the two pass pawns will decide in the
game so after Knight to D7 we have Queen
to C1 Prague has to continue fighting
he's going for that C8 square but also
for the G5 square if if it's going to be
allowed Queen to C6 Magnus stops this
and attacks the Knight on e4 and now
Queen to F4 you have to guard the Knight
and now G captures an F6 finally the
piece is captured e captures on F6 and
now King to H7 we have Queen G4 now
again hoping to get Queen to H5 check-in
but the Magnus just goes Queen to C1
check King H2 and now Queen to H6
stopping any ideas Knight the G5 check
and not Magnus boldly goes in front of
the Knight King to G8 Knight captures on
E6 opens up a discovery from the queen
this comes with check Queen to G6 now
offering a queen trade and queen to C4
now giving up a knight but you will also
win one of the knights depends on how
black defends so F captures an E6 uh
Queen captures an E6 and now Queen to E7
Queen captures an F5 and Knight captures
and F6 and now uh Magnus is up a piece
progress up a pawn uh and uh magnus's
King is completely wide in the open so
can proc do something about this of
course he will try Pawn to G4 uh
Knight's the D5 Magnus very happily
offers a queen trade and of course
Prague has to decline this queen G5
check King to H7 now King to G1 guarding
the F2 Pawn sorry King to G1 guarding
the F2 Pawn uh and uh now Magnus just
starts pushing those pawns like we said
at the beginning of this uh very very
huge line if Prague is unsuccessful in
checkmating magnus's King then the two
connected pass pawns will decide the
game so Queen to D2 and now just Queen
the E6 uh asking uh asking Prague are
you maybe interested in a nice juicy
Pond but then I grabbed the G4 pawn and
for some reason Prague goes for this
queen captures an A5 Queen captures and
G4 with check King to F1 and now Queen
at back to E4 just nicely centralizing
uh probably uh Prague thought that uh
it's best to eliminate at least one of
the pawns but it doesn't help all that
much so Queen to d8 uh we have Knights
the F4 now cutting off the king from
escaping E2 and G2 squares are now
covered Queen to C7 check King H6 with
Queen to B6 with check King H5 Queen to
A5 check and here at Magnus just played
Queen to D5 he blocked check he offered
a queen trade and it was in this
position on move 55 that pregnant
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is if
you trade of course the black's position
is completely winning you're you're up a
piece and you have a pass pawn and if
you don't how are you stopping Checkmate
there's Queen D1 and okay you can block
with Queen T1 but it doesn't help you if
you avoid the queen trade and queen to
H1 is checkmates I also have to worry
about this about this about this
everything is just hanging there there's
nothing you can do
uh so yeah very nicely done by by Magnus
this is the first game of their match uh
we're gonna show the second one and then
we are going to discuss a bit more about
what happened in the penultimate round
as it was kind of a decider for for the
tournament if you if you know what I
mean uh so yeah stay tuned for that uh
probably I'm going to show the next game
between Magnus and Prague because that
is truly is a spectacular one uh has a
has a very long history to it uh some uh
like six six years of History to it uh
if you haven't seen it live you will
enjoy this very much uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank all writer I would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
Luke Bastian and I would like to thank
Francis Sarah Carmen polifrronio
Sinister pawn and Revolution reptiles
YouTube for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on this wonderful tournament until it
finishes so thank you all will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day